if I use the term consciousness in our
lab in our Institute what we mean is the
special quality of mind and the special
features that exist in the mind that
permit us to know for example that we
ourselves exist and that things exist
around us and there is something more
than just mind you know mind allows us
to portray in different sensory
modalities visual auditory olfactory you
name it what we are like and what the
world is like but this very very
important quality of subjectivity this
quality that allows us to take a distant
view and say I am here I exist I have a
life and there are things around me that
refer to me that meanness M II - that is
what really constitutes consciousness in
the heart of consciousness is
subjectivity this sense of having a self
that observes one's own organism and the
world around that organism that is
really the heart of consciousness and
it's very interesting to think about the
distinction with mind which are just
made in very general terms but it can be
made more profound when we think that
there are many species many creatures on
earth that are very likely to have a
mind but are very unlikely to have a
consciousness in the sense that you and
I have there is a self that is very
robust that has many many levels of
organization from simple to complex and
that functions as a sort of witness to
what is going on in our organisms that
kind of process is very interesting
because I believe that it is made out of
the same cloth of mind but it is an
add-on
it is something that was specialized to
create what we call the self and and it
exists for very special purposes and it
has very special and I think by and
large good consequences although not
only good consequences
I think it's possible to a certain
extent to make those comparisons that
the problem is the detail with which the
comparison can be made of course the the
first pass to make such a comparison
would be to ask for a testimony from
different people and have people report
on what they experienced now of course
if the report is going to be about the
quality of sound that one and another
have it's going to be pretty tough to
just go on report even the descriptions
are very precise you you really can't go
very far now there are ways that in
which you can make that distinction
objective to a certain degree for
example by looking at responses that
could be generated in the brain -
exactly the same stimulus and there
could be differences there but there we
remove ourselves from the experience
itself - a surrogate of the experience
which is whatever measure you take from
the brain be it
the electroencephalogram or magnetic
encephalography or say functional
magnetic resonance so it's pretty tough
to make those comparisons one thing that
is for sure though is that when you look
at people that say are from the same
culture roughly the same age in not very
different intelligence and you make a
lot of detailed questions about the
experiences of say colors situations and
so on you get very similar answers so I
think it's it's reasonable to say that
even though in all likelihood we have
slightly different experiences of
reality they are similar enough for us
not to clash in other words I'm not it's
very unlikely in fact let's say
impossible for you to see the situation
in which you and I are in right now
relative to the
the machinery that is capturing this
we're seeing it the same way we're
hearing the same way we have the same
conception of the situation and so for
all the purposes we are operating with a
very similar perception
not more conscious one more conscious
than the other you have different
degrees of the cuteness of the
experience and that has to do with the
amount of concentration amount of focus
that you have on a particular object or
event that your being conscious of and
that there is a lot so for example you
can be highly concentrated on a person
on a problem and and be so good at
excluding all other material that that
becomes not just the focus of your
experience but practically the sole
content of your experience everything
else falling by the wayside and and you
you can achieve that other way you can
achieve that by exercising
that's prerogative and in that I think
that people who are great thinkers in
science or in art people who are great
performers have to have that kind of
capacity without that kind of capacity
it's extremely difficult to manage a
high level of performance because you're
gonna get a lot of extraneous material
chipping away at the finery of your
thinking or the finery of your motor
execution so I think in that sense yes
we can be more or less conscious when
you create grades of focus on a subject
that is flowing in our stream of
consciousness